try anything to raise the cost of
producing jobs I will veto it
that's what you call a quick and to the
point cold open I'm Dave Rubin this is
the Reuben report it's July 13 2023
we're live streaming on Rumble YouTube
and locals if you have not subscribed to
our various channels on the internet
please do uh before I begin I just want
to note because we got a lot of comments
yesterday I got a lot of emails the
locals Community people on YouTube Etc
et cetera a lot of people concerned and
with advice on what to do because I
mentioned that the boys caught some kind
of stomach virus there was a lot of
pooping and puking and diarrhea and all
sorts of stuff and then David got it and
somehow I have escaped this thing but we
cleared the rest of my schedule
yesterday we took care everybody people
are getting better everything's under
control I got a better night's sleep I
think I'll be a little sharper on the
program today but most importantly uh
the boys are on the mend Luke is
actually completely fine Justin was
really great last night he seems to have
kind of gone backwards a little bit this
morning but we think he's on the other
side of it spoke to the pediatrician
it's all good so thank you for your
concern and really thanks mostly to the
moms who offered us all sorts of little
bits of wisdom and advice and and all
that good stuff uh anyway as always
we've got a post game wrap up after the
show if you'd like to join us at
reubenreport.locals.com this morning I
posted a picture of Clyde and asked for
other dog and animal related pictures of
which we have many those are the types
of things that we do on the good side of
the internet not the Facebook Tick Tock
Instagram side that's what we're doing
over there and today's theme ladies and
gentlemen uh it it is not purely
political we're diving back into that
culture War thing we're going to talk
about victimhood
because victimhood seems to be the
driver of so many of the problems of the
day right every day somebody this
happened to me and I was born in America
and I can't do this and he was mean to
me and somehow they think that
victimhood gives them virtue and this is
a huge problem it's completely backwards
right getting what is yours doing what
is right standing up straight with your
shoulders back saying the truth fighting
for what's right those are all the
things that give you purpose that give
you value that help you build a good
world but that is not what the entire
structure or machine as I always call it
uh that's not what it is basically
pushing on the rest of us so the framing
today is about actor Jonah Hill for and
for all the years that I've done the
Reuben report I don't think I've ever
mentioned Jonah Hill before I have no
particular feelings about him one way or
another I liked him in uh Wolf of Wall
Street but he is in the middle of this
big brouhaha right now because a couple
texts that he sent to his now
ex-girlfriend by the name of Sarah Brady
about what he expected of her as a
girlfriend were leaked and people are
saying all sorts of crazy things about
Jonah Hill but he he asked her uh for
some what I would say are pretty basic
functions that you'd have in a
relationship of any kind so we're going
to connect that to some stuff going on
with Dylan Mulvaney he or she has fled
the country and then of course Hunter
Biden and how the media is running cover
for him but how mostly according to the
media everything related to Hunter Biden
is actually Donald Trump and Ron
desantis's fault and what you can do to
empower yourself all right that's an
intro for you let's talk about Mike box
and then get to it I know that you guys
know that sixty percent of U.S pork
production comes from one company owned
by the Chinese their Hogs are given
something called ractopamine which is
banned in 160 countries including China
yet you find it in your grocery aisle
every day well guys there's a better way
I want to tell you about moink that's
moo plus oink moink delivers grass-fed
and grass-finished beef and lamb
pastured pork and chicken and
sustainable wild caught Alaskan salmon
straight to your door you choose the
meat delivered in every box like rib
eyes to chicken breasts pork chops to
salmon fillets and much more plus he can
cancel any time and you guys know that
there's nothing I love doing more than
cooking one of their filet mignons on my
big green egg on a Friday night Shark
Tank host Kevin O'Leary called moink's
bacon the best bacon he's ever tasted
and they guarantee you'll say oink oink
I'm just so happy I got moinked keep
American farming going by signing up at
moinkbox.com Reuben right now and
listeners of this show get free ground
beef for a year that's one of the best
ground beef you'll ever taste but for a
limited time moyfox.com Reuben and how
about New Year all right let's dive into
this Jonah Hill situation and you'll see
why I think this is bigger than just
reading some leaked texts about a
celebrity and you know I don't do that
gossip stuff but I think it connects
directly to so many of the cultural
issues that are wrong these days we've
got some info from the daily wire Jonah
Hill's Surfer ex-girlfriend said she
intentionally waited until after his
current girlfriend had delivered their
first child to go public with
accusations of emotional abuse against
the actor Sarah Brady released a number
of text messages she said were attempts
to control her behavior over the weekend
and she reportedly told her Instagram
followers that she had waited because
she was concerned about the impact her
statements could have on Hill's
girlfriend Olivia mylar especially if
she were to read the text while pregnant
Brady posted a series of texts in which
Hill explained what he expected of her
with the regard to the way she presented
herself if they were going to be dating
seriously one of the texts read plain
and simple if you need surfing with men
boundaryless inappropriate relationships
with men to model to post pictures of
yourself in a bathing suit to post
sexual pictures friendships with women
who were in unstable places and from
your wild recent past Beyond getting
lunch or coffee or something respectful
I am not the right partner for you if
these things bring you to a place of
happiness I support it and there will be
no hard feelings these are my boundaries
for a romantic partnership my boundaries
with you based on the way these actions
have hurt are Trust
so this is rather incredible everything
that she just laid out that he said
about her seems pretty straightforward
don't have sexual relations with other
people ease up on whatever your wild
past might have been don't hang out with
these wild chicks like Jonah did not say
anything crazy there he wasn't abusive
he asked her maybe there was a little
something about dressing a certain way
but I certainly think that a guy in a
chick or two dudes or whatever whoever
you're in a relationship with you're
allowed to talk to your other partner
about that but clearly he was doing it
in a respectful manner so I want to show
you in a moment some of the reactions
some of the mainstream media reaction to
Jonah Hill which again I think you would
by most people's estimation what he said
there there was nothing over the top
about it it was fairly within bounds
certainly not worth leaking or or
anything like that there's a guy by the
name of Sterling Cooper He's a sex coach
for men online he had an interesting
tweet about those texts he said setting
boundaries isn't manipulation it isn't
toxic it isn't misogynistic it's the
only way to have an honest and trusting
relationship Jonah Hill did nothing
wrong men should kick a woman to the
curb if she oversteps his boundaries so
again it's important I think for anyone
in any relationship of any nature you
set some boundaries with your partner
you set some expectations you say these
are the things that are tolerable for me
these are the things that I prefer these
are the behaviors that are acceptable
and not acceptable we all anyone that's
in a relationship that's remotely
functional knows that so by Jonah just
saying those things and there's no
indication that he was being a dick
about it or being abusive about it or
anything he did the right thing and by
the way she had every right to do it to
him right women should do that to men
too these are the behaviors I expect I
don't expect you to be going out with
your old girlfriends all night or
getting drunk with your buddies all
night when you should be home you know
with our kids or whatever it might be
Lauren Chan you guys know Lauren Chen
she's been on the show many times she's
part of the blaze Network a good friend
of mine she was on the Patrick Bet David
podcast yesterday and I thought she had
a nice uh defense of Jonah Hill I could
not imagine a more reasonable sentiment
from a boyfriend not only that but he
communicated very very clearly and very
sensitively I felt he's essentially
saying this is what I expect in a
relationship you are currently not
meeting those standards if you want to
keep going on the way you're going
that's totally fine people have accused
him of being controlling he is not
telling her what to do he is simply
saying I will not be a part of it and
guess what women we are not entitled to
have a boyfriend to have a certain man's
time he is just setting I thought very
reasonable boundaries I know in this
social media age it's for some reason
controversial to say Hey you probably
shouldn't be posting thirst straps I
would say that period but especially if
you're in a relationship so to see
people calling Jonah Hill abusive for
this I was really surprised I was
expecting something really juicy
outrageous when I open the text and then
it's just
okay okay so you might be watching this
so far going Dave what what's the big
deal about this why even bringing up
John Hill this feels like gossip but now
I'm going to connect it to something
much bigger in society and that is how
mainstream media responds to virtually
everything wrong so Phoenix before the
show did a very simple Google search
what was the phrase that you actually
Googled to get this it was
it was just Jonah Hill Sarah Brady and
now we are going to show you we've got
screen captures of it I'm going to read
these headlines and you tell me if that
if these headlines properly capture the
text messages that I just read you uh
this is from stylecaster Jonah Hill text
messages girlfriend Sarah Brady abuse
screenshots Forbes what to know about
Jonah Hill's emotional abuse allegations
from ex-girlfriend that one's almost
Okay Yahoo Jonah Hill's ex Sarah Brady
waited until after his fiancee gave him
birth to accuse him of emotional abuse
Entertainment Weekly Megan McCain
defends Jonah Hill over abuse
allegations the cut Jonah Hill's ex
Sarah Brady accuses him of emotional
abuse Daily Mail Jonah Hill X Sarah
Brady Praises Brave actress Alexa
Nicholas after emotional abuse
allegations accusations Vanity Fair
Jonah Hill accused of emotional abuse by
ex-girlfriend BuzzFeed news join on a
Hill's ex-girlfriend Sarah Brady branded
him emotionally abusive misogynistic
after leaking their alleged texts here's
everything you need to know the forward
was Jonah Hill's ex-girlfriend wrong to
share text showing his abuse he online
Jonah Hill's X Sarah Brady accuses actor
of emotional abuse Huffington Post Jonah
Hill's ex-girlfriend accuses actor of
emotional abuse where'd they come up
with that page six Jonah Hill's X Sarah
Brady blasts him over alleged emotional
abuse so do you see the way the
mainstream media does everything not all
of those are perfectly equal in their
sort of manipulation some of them are a
little more direct but every single one
takes take makes a story out of
something that is completely innocuous
now I get celebrity culture lends itself
to these idiotic click bait stories and
everything else but right now Jonah Hill
who by every estimation did absolutely
nothing wrong and as Lauren Chen points
out it did the right thing set the basic
boundaries
respectfully of what he his expectations
are in a relationship again something
that we all should do in all of our
relationships not only with a
significant other but with with parents
with friends with with everybody right
these are the things that I'm I'm okay
with in the nature of this relationship
right we should all do that we don't
always do it but we should do it right
now all of those corporate press media
Outlets are somehow framing it the
average person who does not read those
articles what what do they now have in
their head Jonah Hill is emotionally
abusive right some of them outright said
it some of them implied it and then they
figure out ways to editorialize once
they write the article but that notion
the notion of just sort of a nothing
burger that becomes a headline and that
headline gets repeated throughout all of
the mainstream media does that sound
familiar does that sound familiar to the
way that for years they lied about
Donald Trump does that sound familiar to
the way lately they've been lying about
Ron DeSantis does that sound familiar to
the way that they run cover say for Joe
Biden or Hunter Biden this is the way
they do it that's why I'm trying to show
you the story we're doing this right
we're pulling back the curtain so I can
show you on the other side but this
notion that you must be a victim to
somehow feel empowered is so freaking
dangerous it perhaps is the most
emotionally dangerous thing that we have
happening in the United States today one
of the Prime movers of this is Dylan
Mulvaney now Dylan Mulvaney is a guy who
I guess did some surgeries and pretends
to be a girl you know the whole brouhaha
with Bud Light which is now caused Bud
Light is no longer not only is it not
just the number one beer in America
which it was before all this it's not
even in the top ten anymore
Anheuser-Busch has lost billions of
dollars in market share companies are
not serving in uh Bud Light at bars
anymore it's stocked up in crazy ways on
shelves at supermarkets but that won't
last any much longer because people just
don't want to buy it anymore anyway
Dylan Mulvaney who caught brought all of
this onto himself right by putting up
these crazy videos pretending to be a
girl I blame also the Bud Light
Executives who got him involved in all
of this but he put this video up he is
currently in Peru at Machu Picchu which
is one of the seven wonders of the world
that we discussed yesterday and he's
still he's still a victim in all of this
hi is this an okay time okay surprise
I'm in Peru and I'm at Machu Picchu
isn't this just so beautiful
um I'm here by myself and I used to do a
ton of solo traveling I'm telling you
it's the best if you could ever do a
solo trip somewhere it is such a good
way to get to know yourself better
um but I came here to feel something you
know what I mean and I definitely have
I've done Shaman ceremonies that were
like 10 years worth of therapy it was
wild
um I've seen a lot of llamas and the
people here are so kind I feel very safe
here it's a little sad that I had to
leave my country to feel safe but that
will get better eventually and I am
dying for some Trader Joe's rolled chili
lime chips but other than that I am so
content still haven't been kissed yet
but I'm holding out hope
and most of all you know this trip has
just has me feeling like I'm My Own best
friend again and that is the best
feeling in the world and I hope that you
feel that way about yourself too
and I love you okay
bye
Machu Picchu wow gorgeous
all right first off as Brock just
pointed out we have no reason to believe
that Dylan Mulvaney is now sponsored by
Trader Joe's I don't want everybody to
now boycott Trader Joe's I have no
problem with Trader Joe's for many many
years I shopped at Trader Joe's that's
not my closest supermarket anymore but
he just happens to like those chili lime
chips at Trader Joe's let's not go crazy
people but this idea that he had to flee
the country but despite doing Shaman
work uh work with shamans right and like
all sort of self-actualization stuff
he's still out there taking the things
oh I had to flee the country this this
like out of control crazy ego thing but
you might be going Dave you've shown us
this Jonah Hill thing and then you said
okay it was just because you wanted to
show us the media reaction the behind
the curtain media reaction why are you
showing this this Dylan Mulvaney thing
we know he's not this great hero or
anything like that who cares well
there's something funny related to the
mainstream media here's CNN Miss
gendering Dylan Mulvaney
we even talked to a bar in Chicago one
bar who was telling us basically they're
not going to serve it because they don't
like the way Delvin Mulvaney was treated
after this whole controversy started he
courses the transgender uh person they
were gonna uh sponsor and go along with
with Bud Light they didn't like how Bud
Light didn't stand by him after all this
yeah it Ryan it's it's really
interesting and great that you got the
temperature
um from people you were talking to it's
one of the it's the culture it's
something it's the culture wars it's a
tough time it is time Ryan young it was
a great story thank you okay so there's
a couple things first off the guy calls
Dylan Mulvaney him and he repeatedly
throughout that right that's that's one
thing that's funny about that did you
catch though that the story is about how
a bar is not serving Bud Light because
they're pissed about Dylan Mulvaney
being sponsored by Bud Light the bar is
no longer serving Bud Light because
they're pissed that Bud Light didn't
back Dylan Mulvaney after all of this so
Bud Light is just getting hit by
everybody which is exactly what they
deserve but because this fella
misgendered Dylan Mulvaney him he
repeatedly yes the next day CNN had to
issue an apology
we do want to make an important note
yesterday in a segment about transgender
influencer Dylan Mulvaney who was
featured in Bud light's recent campaign
she was mistakenly referred to by the
wrong pronoun and CNN aims to honor
individuals ways of identifying
themselves and we apologize for that
she's a guy so
CNN thank you Carter uh CNN wants to
honor people's pronouns Unfortunately
they can't honor journalism that would
be preferred if you asked me but you
know I'm old school but let's continue
that to something else the other so what
they do is they make mountains out of
mole Hills when it comes to certain
things Jonah Hill for example being
totally respectful he will soon be part
of the alt-right you guys know how that
game is played uh but they also Run
cover relentlessly for certain people
and by certain people yes I mean
Democrats we showed you this video the
other day but I I really think it so
illustrates what is wrong with almost
everything so do warning you're getting
something from The View and this is a
this is a double shot it's a Thursday
you're getting the same clip twice in
one week and you're gonna have to judge
whether I'm someone worth listening to
that would do something like this to you
but this is the harpies on The View
running cover for not only Hunter Biden
who's basically ignoring and
disassociating from his biological
daughter
but also Joe Biden who apparently wants
nothing to do with his granddaughter and
there's just so many things wrong with
this watch
and scarring one of his grandchildren's
lives by not publicly embracing her so
apparently his son
had a baby with a woman they've thought
about it and he pays for the for the
baby but he has not embraced the child
so Maureen Dowd is saying it's bad for
the child that the president has not
acknowledged her
so I I kind of think well that's a she
should be fetching at the son whose baby
it is it's not the president's baby so I
don't know what you think but I'm
throwing it out I agree with you
completely it shouldn't have been uh
it's uh
directed to Joe Biden should be directed
to Hunter Biden it's five children not
four Hunter because this is not Joe
Biden's baby and I think it's very hard
for Joe Biden to be a grandfather to the
child if his son is not being a father
he can talk to his child he can advise
Hunter but look what is what is
absolutely evident to me is that the
right wing and the Maga world has
decided to weaponize Hunter Biden
against his dad yeah and everything and
anything Hunter does or does not do is
going to be weaponized and Marine
doubted you guys get it you guys get it
and even Alyssa Farah there at the end
who's the supposed conservative but
she's nothing but a highly paid hack
they run cover for Democrats there is no
reason that Joe Biden and Jill Biden
cannot have a relationship with their
granddaughter he is their biological
granddaughter Hunter Biden may be a
crackhead and an evil bastard and God
whatever else you want to think of
Hunter Biden but that does not mean that
Joe Biden as the grandfather think about
that there are probably hundreds of
thousands probably I wonder if you could
even run numbers on this probably
hundreds of thousands of grandparents in
the United States who are taking care of
their grandchildren night right now
because of parents who have passed away
who are not psychologically able to who
are addicted to substances whatever
because their parents have to work in
other areas whatever the reasons might
be you now have the most privileged
family in America the guys the freaking
president of the United States they are
all worth millions and millions of
dollars the sun is a drug addict and
everything else he most likely left
cocaine at the White House last week
which by the way the FBI and CIA
officially as of this morning they're
just saying now nope we're just done
we're not even gonna look any further
into figuring out whose it was so I'm
pretty sure we know who's it was
um and they're they're concern mostly is
that this is about the right wing it's
about what the right wing will be doing
as I said the other day just imagine
if Donald Trump Jr who doesn't even
drink by the way I've been out with him
many times he does not even take a sip
of alcohol much like his dad doesn't
take a sip of alcohol imagine if he was
a crackhead and imagine if he had a one
night stand with a girl and then wanted
nothing to do with that girl and then
Donald Trump it publicly came out that
Donald Trump wanted nothing to do with
his granddaughter imagine what the
people of the people the the harpies The
Witches the wenches of the view would be
saying about Donald Trump and Donald
Trump Jr but this is what they do and
now this one's even worse this one is
really extraordinary because Jake Tapper
and Jake Tapper I would say is I think
you could describe him as the biggest
disappointment of CNN because when he
was brought in maybe 10 years ago from
ABC News where I think he was the chief
White House correspondent if I'm not
mistaken he was thought of as sort of
like a Centrist like everyone do okay
you're part of the Machinery Democrat
but he was like supposed to be the
non-insane person at CNN right they had
stelter they had lemon they had Acosta
they had like the clown show of people
that obviously were what they were
Tapper was supposed to be the
respectable guy listen to the way he
covered the story about Hunter Biden who
doesn't give an f about his own daughter
and Joe Biden who doesn't give an f
about his granddaughter
and we should point out just for the
sake of fairness that Navy's mom uh who
you know had the uh incident with Hunter
that resulted in this in this beautiful
child uh she has uh been caught up in
some Far Right folks uh some that
Ziegler guy oh right so this isn't
really about Hunter not doing right by
his own daughter or Joe Biden not doing
right by his granddaughter the fact that
they are stopping this girl from using
the Biden name I mean it's so profoundly
disgusting it really is just so
profoundly disgusting and it's
exhausting it's mentally exhausting what
this is really about is somehow the
chick that Hunter banged in the one
night stand she's now associated with
the far right and the alt-right and this
Ziegler guy by the way a little info on
this guy uh Garrett Ziegler he worked
under Trump advisor Peter Navarro and he
had published a 600 page report on
Hunter Biden's abandoned laptop uh when
Roberts was working with Ziegler and may
Biden's legal team appeared concerned
about the former Trump AIDS testimony
and tried to have him disqualified as an
expert that's just a little sidebar on
this eagler guy but that just doesn't
even matter you see the way Jake did
that so subtly instead of what the real
issue here is about Hunter and the
president's grandchild and everything
else it's mostly yeah yeah the chick
she's she's far right she's far right
and speaking of which Chuck Todd who
will soon be out at NBC do we do we have
an exit date for that fraud uh soon
enough he'll be out uh here he is also
with the brilliant framing it's not
really about Joe and Hunter and this
poor kid this is about Trump and
DeSantis
uh before I close boring down Garrett
had a pretty tough piece on on Joe
Biden's uh it was about sort of the
Biden family isn't acknowledging all of
Hunter Biden's children uh it's seven
grandkids Mr President not six I think
we've all understand the personal
challenge
and concern and all of these things that
the that the that the president has here
but his political foes are see this and
they're trying to exploit they're trying
I mean there's no doubt every day
DeSantis or or Trump tries to use Hunter
to beat up Biden
uh how's that world handling it look I
don't think anybody envies the position
that the president and his family are in
on this issue because his family and
Hunter specifically have become his
primary political liability in a lot of
ways I mean look at the cocaine story
from the last week and how many
Republicans have tried to seize on that
cheapness it's really kind of ugly the
way it's been done it's kind of it's
certainly kind of a tacky play here but
I mean look this is as complex as it
gets to have to you know I don't think
all of us here are parents right the
idea of trying to balance your family's
needs versus your political imperatives
is is just just
ugly and unpleasant in politics as we're
going to get and we're going to get way
down that guy's awful I don't know who
that guy is it doesn't even matter who
that guy is but like weighing family and
policy in public and all of that like
it's your grandchild Joe Biden I don't
know uh that you care but that is the
actual truth like it does not matter if
your son was a great guy or an awful guy
or a crackhead or a fraud or Mr
Wonderful or anything else it's still
your grandchild and the way they run
cover and it's really guys what this is
really about is how Republicans how Ron
DeSantis and Donald Trump are using this
and look at the way they focused on the
cocaine at the white house because
surely if cocaine was found at a
republican white house uh they'd be
trying to run cover for that it's so
just
absolutely ridiculous the next version
of course of all of this is that when
anyone does anything
to stand up and fight the machine they
just come for you relentlessly so one of
the things I've been talking about a lot
lately is how it's very odd to me
although I think if you just think about
it a little bit deeper it's not that odd
that the New York Times and Washington
Post and MSNBC really are on the same
side as Donald Trump right now when it
comes to Ron DeSantis so here is a New
York Times Reporter uh James Jane
coastin going after DeSantis because
he's campaigning now she's a lefty of
course but he's campaigning in a way she
doesn't like so he must be awful and bad
he is an actual governor of an actual
State he has a lot of things he could
talk about especially to an audience of
Republicans that are tired of trump they
are tired of just acrimony they want to
get things done and they have you know
there's here's a governor of a state
that is doing well that he he was more
than victorious in his re-election
campaign and now he's running to be like
to you know appeal to people on 4chan
what is this it's a very strange
campaign when he could be talking about
how he opened up Florida and defeated
covid
whatever and instead he's like no I am
going to run as the most right-wing Edge
Lord person you've ever seen on the
internet
poor Chan Edge Lord like I don't know
what the hell she's talking about
DeSantis whether you like the Santos or
not and I know a lot of you that watch
this show do like the santis I obviously
like this at this I know a lot of you
would prefer Trump that's just fine I'll
support whoever the ultimate nominee is
certainly more than any kind of democrat
um but like this is just this analysis
is just pure dribble but this is what is
on corporate press on the uh on the
weekends on these Sunday shows it's just
nonsense DeSantis has run a campaign
that you may you may not like the
campaign you may not like the direction
he's going in and clearly she's an
activist not a journalist so she doesn't
like DeSantis but he's run on look what
I've done on kovid Lakota I'm fighting
the woke look what I did with Disney
look how I'm getting ESG out of our
institutions here it's he's run on pure
policy but no he's run as on 4chan at
first I've never even been on 4chan I
don't know exactly what 4chan is yeah
your eyes just like lit up like nobody
wants to be on four I don't even I
genuinely don't even know exactly what
it is it's like the total like Cesspool
of the internet I guess at an edge Lord
like Edge Lord that phrase is usually
thought of as like you're one of these
people that's online always going after
people and trolling like that's far more
Trump than it is DeSantis but you can
see who they really fear but I want to
show you this one if you want to see
really like the corporate press this
might be the best example it never stops
but this might be the best example of
how corrupt they are this is Business
Insider uh yesterday was this yesterday
or two days ago the first article is the
original more people actually moved out
of Florida than New York or California
in 2021 and then of course it gets
ratioed to high hell and then two it was
it two hours later we got it wrong more
people moved out of New York and
California than Florida in 2021. the the
author of the piece what's the name of
the person the others
Kelsey neubauer or something Kelsey
neubauer this person literally took the
numbers and just reversed them it's
roughly 670 000 people in 21 alone 2021
alone that moved to Florida she
literally she or he I don't know it
doesn't even matter and she might be he
literally just reversed the numbers and
then printed an article that gets by all
the editors of Business Insider and that
it isn't until the internet is like what
the are you talking about that they
reverse it but once again guys you get
it the the the these accidents they only
go in One Direction right so they love
victimhood they love running cover for
all of the bad people they love running
cover for the bad policies and
everything else and speaking of bad
people and bad policies I thought this
was a good one Maxine Waters you guys
remember Maxine Waters I haven't talked
about her for quite some time she's a
representative in Los Angeles she
represents a very economically depressed
area that's not where she lives though
she lives in Hancock Park which is one
of the richest areas in all of Los
Angeles I think she has about a five
million dollar mansion God bless her I
don't know how she made all that money
in this oppressive racist state that we
live in uh but again that's not the
district that she represents uh she here
uh explaining why we must have ESG now
ESG this corporate index meaning
corporations must follow certain climate
policies diversity initiatives all of
these things this modern woke nonsense
that combines government with
corporations which is known as fascism
here's Democrat representative Maxine
Waters Progressive lunatic explaining
why we need ESG
it's become a dirty word for Corporate
America it's gotten so politicized
it certainly has gotten politicized and
it's unfortunate because it's inevitable
uh that everyone is going to have to
participate in dealing with the
environmental crisis social uh activity
and of course uh corporate governance
and so even if these attempts uh to deny
or to delay are taken place in the in
the final analysis we're going to have
to have EST and so yes uh we're paying a
lot of attention to it uh we're going to
fight back against these attempts to
deny or destroy uh the whole idea of
environmental of Social and governance
uh but we have to do it in order to save
this planet
all right first off the woman looks like
an old catcher's mitt you remember when
you have an old baseball glove and you
oil it up and you put a baseball in it
and you wrap it up with with a tie and
you put it under your bed so that you
can kind of break it in a little bit and
over time you take it out and you look
at that thing and I had my baseball
glove when I was growing up was it had
Ozzie Smith in the middle remember Ozzie
Smith shortstop The Wizard of Oz from
the St Louis Cardinals that was my glove
she looks like Ozzie Smith's glove she
also looks like a California Raisin
that's for you people to decide I leave
that to you and I'm also open in the
comments if you want to leave anything
else she looks at like that's just fine
there but do you see who the fascists
are what she is saying is we want to use
the government through ESG to force
corporations to do what we cannot force
people to do on their own so if we can't
push through all of the climate nonsense
that we want to push we want to make
corporations sign on to pledges saying
they will do x y and z for the climate
we can't know we can no longer
discriminate in the government based on
diversity Equity inclusion they still do
it in their own way and I think that'll
get up to the Supreme Court as well we
obviously won the affirmative action
case last week but we know that the
government is clearly using diversity
equity and inclusion when it comes to
hiring but she's saying corporations
must do it too what right does the
government have to tell a corporation
what color of skin the people they are
going to hire have to have it is this is
literally fascism the Democrats are
Fascist at this point
excuse me at this point which is why
they call everybody else fascist because
that is one of the basic ideas that they
have done extremely well accuse
everybody else of doing the very thing
that you are doing
but what else
do they love besides neo-racism and
chopping children's genitals off well of
course it's the climate thing I think
this is one of the stupidest tweets I've
ever seen in my entire life this is
former presidential candidate Amy
Klobuchar Democrat from Minnesota this
is the hottest summer on record for the
entire world that's why we passed the
inflation reduction act to significantly
decrease greenhouse gases the time to
act is now not tomorrow not 50 years
from now just to be clear people leave
the Tweet up for just a moment she is
trying to tell you that the inflation
reduction act which did not reduce
inflation actually it increased
inflation because we just printed money
thus devalued money so money became
worth less that increased inflation that
that somehow is going to stop climate
change and I thought instead of giving
my opinion on this it reminded me of
something
that's not how it works that's not how
any of this works that's right those two
old women from the Geico commercial
giving you political analysts uh
political analysis on Amy Klobuchar just
absolutely ridiculous but let's connect
this to something else for a moment this
need to be a victim right I am a victim
my boyfriend wanted me to dress a
certain way and not be banging other
dudes I am a victim because I was part
of a giant marketing campaign it didn't
go the way I wanted so now I have to be
alone in Machu Picchu I am a victim
because the government isn't allowing me
to force my employees to do whatever it
wants me to do I will endlessly
and moan about everything while I live
in the greatest place in the history of
the world I don't know what accent I'm
doing enough of the victimhood guys I
saw this video this is my buddy Michael
Knowles from the daily wire doing a
college event and they were not happy
with him they were screaming they they
were shouting they were trying to
silence a speaker on college campuses
which we all know all too well and
Knowles mocked the victims of the faux
oppression quite well I know you're so
oppressed my dears I know life is so
hard for you you have to live in the
richest most Equitable most just country
in the history of the world you have to
get a college education you have to
voluntarily go to lectures it's so awful
I can't imagine that you know the people
people who are in war-torn Nations they
must truly they must truly fit you
goodbye goodbye then
[Applause]
yeah
what the hell is even that
look
these kids you can't blame the kids
right you can't at some point like we
can make fun of these kids and okay it
is what it is but like you can't blame
the kids the education system have
spelled them their parents have failed
them the institutions have failed them
the school there has failed them by not
teaching them the right things
everything has failed them and next
thing you know they're morbidly obese
their penis is a vagina and they're a
little pissed you maybe you wonder why
so guys what is the solution to all of
this well it's a lot of the stuff that
obviously Jordan Peterson talks about
it's some of the stuff that I've been
showing you that Andrew Tate's been
talking about it's some of the things
that I've been trying to talk about here
just like
kind of get your roughly together
and see what you can do with the world
like that pretty much sums it up uh but
Patrick Bet David from valutainment he
had a nice little Soliloquy on why
victimhood mentality is not attractive
all of us tend to go there sometimes
well man I've been working so hard
lately you chose to be a CEO let me tell
you all this pressure stop no you had
kids nobody told you to have unprotected
sex well let me tell you you know how
life is being a single man you chose to
become single nothing is attractive
about victimhood mentality it's got
nothing to do with Left Right middle
Center black white asian Middle Eastern
women men gay straight no one cares stop
being a victim it's not attractive
that is literally it but if the
Democrats did not have
however we don't know how many people it
is but they still win elections one way
or another if if a certain amount of
people in this country had not been so
brainwashed to be NPCs and just to have
no drive to do anything other than burn
everything down man we still have it so
good and that is the challenge for all
of us to find that goodness to find the
good people and go out there and and
build things you know yesterday as I was
being pooped on repeatedly I mean
full-on Diary of blowing out of diapers
puked on like it was I was holding the
remote I was holding I was holding
Justin
you know and he's having a rough day
we're doing our thing and one of the one
of the few things that was calming him
down do you know this woman Miss Rachel
if if you don't have kids you probably
don't know her but if you have kids you
know this woman it's one of it's the
only thing we let the kids watch this
woman Miss Rachel she's got a great way
with young children that it feels like
it's learning and it's not too many
colors and it's not too fast whatever it
was the one thing calming him down so I
picked up the remote to put on Miss
Rachel and I'm holding him and I have
the remote and diarrhea through all over
the remote all but I didn't complain I
didn't complain it's life if anything by
the end of the day I was like boy I had
a hell of a day today I had a hell of a
day today and there's something
important going on here with being a
parent being a father and doing what
you're supposed to do I want to go with
one other thing that Patrick David said
this was a tweet that he put out
yesterday that I thought also kind of
caught this really nicely uh Alphas find
each other bitter bitter people find
each other entitled people find each
other positive people find each other
big thinkers find each each other those
who blame the find each other critical
thinkers find each other those who can
reason find each other criminals find
each other party animals find each other
Gamers find each other those who believe
in God find each other atheists find
each other complainers find each other
your circle is a direct reflection of
you you attract who you relate to I like
my circle to be driven competitive able
to reason fun loyal supportive while
constantly in the hunt for the next
Milestone if you don't like your circle
start by changing your mindset then
identify which types of people you want
in your circle eventually your circle
will upgrade
well ladies and gentlemen that is our
show for today I think that you uh are
in my circle I hope you consider me
someone that's in your circle even if
not in real life we do it through these
electronic wires and I think we are in
on this thing together and we as I
always say we got a chance to fix it if
you want to join us for the post game
show uh jump over right now to
reubenreport.locals.com don't forget we
have an IOS app if you're using the
iPhone we've got a Android app if you're
using the uh
Android I guess it is if Samsung or
whatever that other phone is if you're
using one of those we got an app for
that too uh part one of my interview
with RFK Jr is up across platforms full
things up ad free at locals right now we
leave you with a comedian who we lost
way way way too early this is sort of
separate from anything we did today I
just thought it was funny a little Norm
McDonald and we'll see everybody on the
other side ciao
and that I want to season here
he became the first defensive player to
win the Heisman Trophy and
congratulations Charles that is
something that no one can ever take away
from you unless you kill your wife and a
waiter in which case
professor
uh it's a word of advice
[Music]
mode